В нас є група в Facebook села.
Ну [села] Станіслава, Олександрівки —
і я один з модераторів цих груп.
Я десь 2 роки як почав викладати фотографії з коптера,
квіти та іншу красу.
Люди почали такі дивитись.
Кажуть: «О, чуваки! Це що, в нас?»
«У нас так красиво?»
В дитинстві тут була човнова станція:
з катамаранами та човнами.
Я пам'ятаю початок 1990-х, коли були розвали,
і люди ці всі човни розтягнули.
А до 1990-х ти приходив на берег і не мав,
де взяти човен в прокат, бо всі зайняті були.
Катамарани, човни.
В Станіславі, до речі, був яхт-клуб.
Тренувальна база абощо, там ще навіть
титуловані спортсмени займалися.
Завжди була ідея починати з чогось водного.
Мої діди-прадіди тут [в селі] іще з 19 століття.
Одні з перших переселенців,
а Петровича — іще давніші.
Я повернувся, коли 2008 року криза бабахнула.
У мене з роботою проблеми почалися,
і я такий: «Треба щось міняти».
Я жив у Кривому Розі тоді.
Звільняюсь з роботи, приїжджаю в село
і сиджу три місяці депресую.
Справді не знаю, що робити і...
У мене завжди було хобі —
фотозйомка і відеозйомка.
Два роки тому я зняв кілька роликів
про цю місцевість.
То було взимку: знімав гори.
Воно облетіло інтернет:
за тиждень декілька десятків переглядів.
Андрюха підтягнувся і я йому кажу:
«Чуваче, давай будемо розвивати туризм».
— А нам всі кажуть: «Туризму»...
— А я йому: «Ото ти і бахнувся».
Кажуть: «Туризму тут нема».
Одеса — дуже велике місто.
Мабуть, не кожному можна вжитися й
увійти в стихію того міста.
До всього, в мене народилася дочка.
Подумалось, що, напевне,
краще свою дитину
ростити в здоровому місці,
на здорових продуктах,
в здоровому оточенні.
Щоб вона бачила оцю красу,
спробувала цю воду.
Купили байдарки, почали скручувати, ну симулянки.
Байдарки — це щось нове тут.
Байдарки — це... От Нижнє Дніпро, плавні
і тут байдарки ніколи не використовували.
Навіть ті спортсмени, які тренуються в Херсоні,
ніколи сюди не запливали.
Тут хвиля...
— Тут же більш відкрита вода, широка вода і...
— Дуже залежить від погоди.
Так, від погоди.
Також дуже круто ходити в хвилі.
Якщо хтось любить Біловоди як в гірських річках,
то реально дуже круто [тут плавати].
Це безпечно, [байдарки] не перевертаються,
частка екстриму є.
Тут ти йдеш прямо по відкритій воді,
а тут — заходиш тихенько:
пташки, звірина якась там...
До речі дуже круто, що пташки...
Ти не лякаєш цих пташок,
знаєш всю цю живність.
Вони дуже тихо йдуть.
Ти підпливаєш [за] 20 метрів:
чаплі ходять там, пелікани сидять.
Дуже круто.
Плануємо зробити дитячу школу.
Не знаю настільки це нам вдасться,
наскільки це реально й перспективно.
Не знаємо, з чого почати.
Так, не знаємо з чого почати,
але хочемо цим займатись з дітьми.
Такий соціальний проєкт.
Нещодавно почув від місцевих дітей 13-15 років,
що більшість з них не вміють плавати.
Ті, хто тут виросли.
Для нас у віці шести-семи років
це було на кшталт: «Не вмієш плавати?»
— Це немислимо.
— Щось на кшталт того.
А є такі діти, які навіть за все життя тут
жодного разу на воді не були.
Вони не знають туризму,
крім як поніжитись на морі на пляжі —
їх там батьки возять.
Хочеться їм показати — от туризм,
він може бути таким.
Коли виїжають або бачать фотографії
з наших виїздів, вони [питають]: «О! А де це?»
«Та сто метрів від твоєї хати».
Ніхто не вірить, що то так гарно,
навіть місцеві позабували.
Це так само як одесити ніколи
не бувають на морі,
а ті, хто живуть в Карпатах,
ніколи не ходять на Говерлу.
Так само ті, хто живуть тут,
ніколи не бувають на прогулянках,
ніколи не бачать цієї краси,
ніколи не їздять на півника дивиться,
весною, коли цвітуть дерева у балках.
Там дехто каже: «А чого ви не фоткаєте сміття?
[Не показуєте], як тут загажено всьо?»
Я кажу: «Якщо будемо привчати людей
до чогось гарного,
то може люди почнуть це бачити
і самі [скажуть]:
"Та ні, я не буду викидати сміття,
бо тут круто"».
Останні два роки ми сюди приїжджаємо,
і щоразу все менше сміття.
Можна відкрити магазинчик
і тобі буде крапати якийсь прибуток.
Типу все гаразд.
Будь-хто це може зробити.
У мене по життю така річ,
що я щось роблю...
Те, що в апріорі трошки ненормальне.
Добре, що в мене є дружина,
яка підтримує мої дурнуваті ідеї.
Сім'я — це проєкт.
А коли один проєкт допомагає іншому,
це взагалі круто.